Tamm you're Catholic right yes explain
it to me
explain what well for starters who do
you pray to I guess
Jesus God and Mary Jesus isn't God no
he's his son but you do eat him and
drink his blood
oh there's also a ghost but not the
scary kind like Casper exactly and how
does the Pope work well the Pope lives
in Italy he has a special car and a big
pointy hat it's a wonderful hat and is
there anything else I should know about
every once in a while you're the
confessor sins to a priest not me I
don't have any sense then you have the
sin of pride your religion is making me
feel bad that's how you know is working
miss Hutchins what's your religion I'm a
Mormon
why I'm conducting a research project
can you tell me about being a Mormon
well it started in New York when a man
found gold plates buried underground the
plate said that when we Dowe we get to
go to our own planet unless you're a
woman then you have to go to your
husband's planet but that won't be a
problem for me I don't have a husband
all I have is a cat a big main cat maybe
I'll get to go to his planet only share
along beylin captain I like her she's
funny so seldom ya hungry you want a
nice I don't know I've never eaten a
nosh oh that isn't thing it's a then
what would you care for some hard candy
or they kosher how are you my mother
all right so what can I do for you
what's it like to be Jewish oh it's
terrible I don't recommend it why
well for starters your life is hemmed in
by ancient pointless rules it's a lot of
yelling and you're probably not gonna
get into a good Country Club what about
God what about him
does he play a part in your life well
historically he's gotten a kick out of
punishing us what about Jesus he was
Jewish well we got a lot of celebrities
we've got we've got William Shatner
Leonard Nimoy Kirk and Spock I want to
be Jewish hold on a second well I got a
question for you Sheldon when you grow
up are you planning on living in Texas
probably then I strongly advise you to
stay Baptist maybe even wear a cross why
did you move to Texas well that's simple
Medford had no Jews so there was an
opening for one and you got it good for
you
hey I love this kid me too
[Music]
you